right so this is the third talk in a
session both of the previous talks are
related to this work these three papers
came up simultaneously
and so I'll try to contrast the three
papers the sample complexity of
estimating entropy this is joint work
with Jaidev acharya on and theta suresh
and along on litski this was done while
I was at ITA as a postdoc and now I'm
here this January so why why do we want
to estimate entropy well in many
applications many many many applications
I don't know that I don't know the
details of these applications but if
there are many of them all of these all
of these applications are papers with
very high citations okay so in many
application people estimate entropy as a
measure of randomness they want to
estimate somehow the randomness in the
data which is which is available and
they assume some kind of generating
model they're generative model there the
usual proxy for measure of randomness in
data is entropy and in particular it's
usually
all right it's usually the Shannon
but you better pause it otherwise we
will continue advancing on you both no
yeah it shows up this thing okay so
usually is the Shannon entropy which is
what the previous talks were talking
about so people would like to estimate
randomness in the data and the proxy
they use for it is Shannon entropy so
what do I mean by that well as I
explained by yee hong who you have an
unknown distribution P a discrete
distribution P with unknown support size
K and we want to estimate the Shannon
entropy of this distribution P the
question is how many samples do we need
for reliable estimation and this first
unknown is fine the second unknown is
unknown in a good way so when we
designed the estimator we don't know K
but when we show lower bounds the
previous who talks when they showed
lower bounds they showed lower bounds
even when you know K so this second
unknown isn't a good way in the sense
that lower bounds hold even when you
know K so you want to estimate this
Shannon entropy and how many samples do
we need for estimating the Shannon
entropy P H of P so we are in a PAC
framework or large deviation guarantees
so we have n iid samples and iid samples
from P and there is an estimator which
we design a chart for estimating this
entropy of P so we look at probably
probably approximately correct bounds so
probably with large probability
approximately correct bounds okay what
is the least number of samples n that
you need for a sample for an estimator H
hat to work that's what s of H hat delta
epsilon k is and the sample complexity
of estimating Shannon entropy is defined
as the minimum number of samples that
you need over all possible estimators
for estimating the Shannon entropy up to
an accuracy of Delta with probability
greater than 1 minus epsilon K that we
have worried about and in particular we
want the dependence on K so the previous
talk did a very exhaustive literature
review about the results here are some
of those results so asymptotically
consistent and normal estimators are
known for
tyne have been known for a long time in
2003 penance key studied the sample
complexity bounds for this problem and
he gave first for instance he showed
that empirical estimator requires of
liquor samples then remarkably sure that
there is some estimator actually it's a
linear estimator as you have explained
it there are these linear estimate so
it's a linear estimator and it needs
less than K samples for estimating and
trophy so which is interesting because
you probably don't need to see all the
symbols before you estimate entropy and
then in this remarkable people have a
valiant and valiant all the three talks
calls paper remarkable so it must really
really be remarkable it is really
remarkable in this remark your paper by
valiant and valiant they showed that
actually you can estimate entropy using
K over log K samples theta K over log K
samples so both upper and lower bounds
make set off by a constant factor the
proposed estimator was based on linear
programming and you can try reading this
paper it's not the easiest paper to read
so what happened what happened recently
in this two papers is a simple proof of
the same result was given and there were
some some results were sharpened okay so
this is what we saw in the previous talk
so here is the result estimating Shannon
entropy requires K over log K samples
and gentle mentioned that some people
don't care about this log K factor yeah
probably
most people don't care about the log K
factor so it's not a very good result in
the sense that it's a negative result
because it's saying that to estimate
entropy you need roughly as many samples
as you need to estimate the distribution
itself with all the K samples you can
actually estimate the distribution and
now we are saying we can estimate and
croupy using K over log K samples so
it's kind of a negative result question
is can we do better is there some other
notion of entropy Riya we can do better
okay can we do let's say sub linear in K
fine so so what are the other notions of
entropy well there's an X Co metric
definition of Shannon entropy there are
four exams and the unique cancellation
and entropy if you drop one of the eggs
iam you get this another family of
entropy is namely the Rainey entropy
okay so Rainey entropy
another fundamental measure of
randomness its defined this way in fact
in many many applications when he
entropies even more fundamental than
Shannon entropy
there are many operational significance
of the Iranian rupee and in particular
in cryptography Raney entropy is the
fundamental quantity shows up in the
leftover hash lemma which is the biggest
constructive tool for all cryptographic
protocols in a way so it's a more
fundamental notion for some applications
and estimating variant ropey is of
interest in its own right we don't have
to relate it to Shannon entropy as such
on the other hand if you're just looking
for a proxy for measure of randomness
this is a good proxy so you can work
with this I can sell it to data
scientist already I sold it to a guy in
the department next to my department is
a neuroscientist he was estimating
Shannon ropey I told him why don't you
estimate Raney entropy said sure so so
so you can sell it it's easy to sell so
another thing is that in the limit alpha
going to 1 this converges to Shannon
entropy so that's there so now the
question is how many samples do we need
for estimating greenie entropy just like
we asked for Shannon entropy what is the
sample complexity of estimating learning
Iranian tropi we want dependence on
alpha and we can have dependence on
Delta and epsilon and kak is the support
size but we don't really care about
epsilon and Delta right now because we
don't have the answer we only care about
that on the dependence of alpha and K
okay in particular we want to know for
which alpha is it easiest to estimate
there any entropy
all right that's the question so the
answer which Lenny entropy is the
easiest to estimate there are some
notations I just learned that this is
called quasi linear lower bound in the
last talk or something so this basically
says that s alpha K is the exponent the
exponent of K is almost beta so when
beta is less than 1 this is called quasi
linear I didn't know if this formality
before today so basically this is that
the exponent is almost K this one says
that you can do it in K to the power
beta and theta rotation we want to know
what that is so after this heavy
notations we can
we have slightly we can state a results
in slightly better form so here is the
result if alpha is less than 1 then s
alpha K is actually worse than
estimating Shannon entropy it's K to the
power 1 over alpha you need at least K
to the power 1 over alpha samples so
it's even worse than linear is super
linear on the other hand if alpha is
less than 1 alpha is greater than 1 then
you can do you still require linear
samples provided alpha is not integer so
you still require linear as many samples
and so the still there is no good news
we're still as bad as Shannon entropy
but of course there has to be a good
news paper got accepted somewhere so the
good news is this alpha greater than 1
alpha integer you can do really well you
have a theta result s alpha K is K to
the power 1 minus 1 over alpha so so
just so alarming yeah disturbing so I'll
come to that so here is the graph if I
plot the exponent of K for alpha less
than 1 this is this is K to the power 1
over alpha so the exponent is 1 over
alpha really bad for also greater than 1
on integer it's K so 1 exponent but
there are these jumps at integer values
and in particular trainee Entropia of
order 2 is the easiest to estimate
requires only square root K samples but
that's why my biology are the guy who
sits in this bio Center likes many
Entropia followed to neuro but the
center is biobots a neuro guy from
Stanford actually so so it requires
square root K samples so discontinuity
is alarming especially because RNA
entropy is continuous in alpha for each
fixed distribution P but I don't know
the correct answer why it's there one
one thing it is not uniformly continuous
in P it's only continuous in so it's not
uniformly continuous for all P its
countries in alpha for any fixed P but
Raney entropy is not uniformly
continuous and so we don't and we don't
know P so that's why this jumps can
occur okay but the point is it's very
easy to estimate
Raney and toki of integer orders and in
particular Rainie entropy of order 2 is
the easiest to estimate
so now I move to the proof I won't show
how to get this lock k improvement this
is based on polynomial approximations
which the first two talks talk about
talked about and in fact if you don't
care about this lock K improvement then
the empirical estimator achieves these
bounds and for the third one will give
us new estimator the interesting thing
here is the lower bound which are very
simple to derive you actually okay so
this is the result so just a just a
quick remark about
relation to other works in particular
the previous talk so another related
problem is estimating what is called
power some it was called moments but
that might be confusing so estimating
power sum of a distribution P is just
this quantity here so it's very obvious
that estimating grainy entropy is
tantamount to estimating the power some
multiplicatively so with small
multiplicative error so there's a
relation between estimating a power sums
with a relative error and estimating
person with multiplicative error it
turns out there was already some work
about estimating integer moments of
frequencies in a sequence with small
multiplicative and additive errors this
work was there in 2001 and then one what
jean tout talked about was estimating
possum's with small additive error so
here is a relation between additive and
multiplicative error if you remember
previous talk I'm sure most of you to
remember it so if alpha is less than 1
then if alpha is less than 1 then the
sample complexity for small additive and
multiplicative error is comparable it's
almost the same if alpha is greater than
1 then under additive whether you need
constantly many samples on the other
hand our answers say our results is that
for multiplicative accuracy you need
linear if alpha is not integer and even
if alpha is interior you need still K to
the power of and my 1 minus 1 over alpha
so they're completely different answers
are completely different in the regime
when alpha is greater than 1 which is
the interesting regime for us and when
alpha is less than 1 they are comparable
okay one heuristic for this is that
actually variant rupee for alpha greater
than 1 is bounded above by 1 by K to the
power alpha minus 1 so it's very small
so if you try to sorry these persons are
bounded by this very small already
so if you're looking for a small
multiplicate additive error then the
quantity itself is very small so it
makes sense to look for small
multiplicative Ellery okay fine so this
is the review of results and I'll move
to the proof now so start with our
estimators the first estimator is
obviously the plug in estimator so what
is the plug in estimator well you just
estimate the empirical frequency and the
multiplicity and X of a symbol X
normalize it by N and just plug in that
quantity into the formula for Raney
entropy so this is your estimate for
rainy entropy turns out it's not bad
gets us all our bounds except the law of
factors since we are improving the
linear bounded cell we don't care about
the log path we improving the exponent
itself okay so what we can show is that
for the empirical estimators you need
roughly K sample the sample complexity
is bounded above by a flick key K times
some things which are that which are
ugly forget about them because they are
not even optimal probably but K here for
alpha greater than 1 and K to the power
1 over alpha for alpha less than 1 how
do we get these results so I know the
techniques for deriving these kind of
results were reviewed in previous two
talks but was a long coffee break so
let's review it again so first first
thing is that estimating Raney entropy
with small additive error is this as I
said is it's the same as estimating
power some with a small multiplicative
error so we can just look at estimating
power sums with small multiplicative
error then thing I think you hyung
explained this in great details so you
can always reduce this back bounds or
this large deviation bounds to showing
bounds on variance and bias of P hat I'm
it's a small it's a well-known set of
tricks it's called the median trick and
it's very simple before I knew it before
I've seen it it's not obvious or derive
immediately but once you see it's very
simple so it's a fight is to show that
the bias and the variance of an
estimator are multiplicative Li small so
that's all we'll show which show that
the bias and the aliens are
multiplicative lee small and they'll
employ imply the
large deviation bombs second trick of
course was our sampling all our results
are in terms of these empirical
frequencies n X they can be correlated
so that's a problem in bounding the
variance so we have this theoretical
tool called positive sampling under
which it's a different way of generating
the samples but it turns out that if you
can show bounds and the positive
sampling then that will imply a bound
under regular sampling that's the main
idea what is the advantage well these
multiplies are these multiplicities are
independent on the course of sampling so
it helps you with various bounds
actually you don't need it in this case
it turns out although they are
correlated they are negatively
correlated so there are other techniques
which you can use to get around this but
both of sampling is a good tool to use
so they're independent now so we will
consider positive sampling what do I
mean the number of samples is a positive
and I'm very bad with rate small and the
actual number of samples and we have X 1
to X capital n independent samples from
P but this n was possible okay so this
is two things so here is the bound on
bias and variance very simple actually
it looks ugly but this this calculations
are I think they are nice it's requires
some work which is interesting but yeah
somehow suggestions about making this
more beautiful are welcome okay so this
bias the multiplicative bias is small
I'm normalizing here by P alpha P and
multiplicative variance is small that's
what this means the the biases of the
order K by n to the power something and
so you see K by n everywhere
that's why n should be of the order K
here again you see K by n that should
that's why I and K are comparable and
you see K to the power 1 over alpha by n
okay so these are the bounds that we get
and from that these bounds arise so in
the end we just showed that the bias and
variance are multiplicatively small
that's the difference between previous
two talks in this talk so this was an
empirical estimator
now the actual estimator which we use
for the integer case is a bias corrected
version of that of the empirical
estimator and since we are working with
pause on sampling we correct the bias
and the pause on sampling if we carried
analysis under regular sampling we could
have corrected the bias
regular sampling that would also work
but we are working in Paulo sampling so
we will correct the bias and the Poisson
sampling so this n to the power alpha is
the alpha at falling power of n so it's
n into n minus 1 into n minus alpha plus
1 so that's what it is
note make of a simple observation that
if you have a Poisson random variable
with rate lambda and the expected value
of X to the power alpha falling per is
actually lambda to the power alpha
in other words H to the power falling
power alpha is an unbiased estimator of
the land of the lambda to the power
alpha so when you are looking when we
were using the plug-in estimator we were
estimating px and plugging it into the
formula for P H to the power alpha now
we are directly estimating P X to the
power alpha that's what this one does
and for estimating X to the power alpha
we use an unbiased estimator of P X to
the power alpha which can be done
because alpha is an integer that's
that's the idea here
so this is the estimate just define the
power sum as this quantity here we are
estimating this is this is because
suppose our random variable of rate n
times PX this becomes n to the power
alpha times P X to the power alpha and
we get this estimate here well this is
our estimator it's the bias corrected
estimator it's correcting the bias for
the multiple for the power sum problem
not it's not unbiased for the entropy
estimation problem as such okay so this
is a bias collected estimator of course
the bias is now zero so multiplicative
by suppose to 0 the multiplicative
variance can be bounded with a very nice
expression good thing about this bound
is break that is that it shows that the
constants can be really small
theoretically small okay the theta
notation is not hiding very big
constants I can ask the previous two
authors to talk about the constants but
smaller the related term
my understanding is that most of the
constants in literature in this
literature are big at least
theoretically these constants are
theoretically small okay because this is
the constant which we get you can see
the constant from this expression I
don't know this I don't know what a
small constant is okay so so this is the
bound that we get on an on the sample
complexity for this bias corrected
estimate
so to summarize the other three upper
bounds the first two are obtained by
empirical and a third one is obtained by
the bias credited estimator and now we
move to the Oh before that so small
constants just to nail down that we have
small constants here are some simulation
results the upper graphs are for uniform
distribution the lower ones are for zip
distribution you can see that if you
have a distribution with about 10,000
samples then you start performing really
well around of 600 700 samples so this
red line is the medium of few estimates
it's the median of few estimates and in
fact that boosting trick actually uses
median of you estimate so this is
actually the estimator that they're
using and it's very close to the actual
value of entropy when you are 6 times
square root K of ok so the constant this
experiment shows the constant to be
about 6 maybe but it's not 6
theoretically it's about 300 ok but
experiments do show it's better than
probably what for these distribution is
better than what we were imagining them
to be okay so these are our graphs this
show things work well in practice ok now
the lower bounds I just have 4 minutes
left I think so
the general approach for lower bounds
how do you show lower bounds in such
problems how do you show sample
complexity lower bounds even talked
about it so to show that the sample
complexity is bounded below by G K G's
some function of K for all Delta and
epsilon sufficiently small we show that
there exist two distribution P and Q so
that the support side is roughly K there
entropies are off by some Delta but you
can't distinguish between P and P n and
Q 1 so if you see the samples you can't
distinguish between P N and Q 1 because
the variation distance is really small
so that's the trick construct these two
distributions with small variation
distance with different iranian rupees
and with supports Ice King roughly Klee
ok this is the construction that we seek
we can do better we don't have to look
at these joint distributions of P N and
Q n we can look at some sufficient
statistic so you can because you can't
do anything better than sufficient
statistic so you can show that the
distribution induced by P and on
sufficient statistic and QN and
sufficient statistics have a small
variation distance that's the second
part of the trick so this is the
construction we will do what sufficient
statistic is
easy-to-use here well profiles profile
is a good sufficient statistic to use
here so just quickly this CIA is the
ayat so profile is an n-dimensional
vector the ayats entry is the number of
symbols appearing i times in action
that's my ayat' entry of the profile so
number of symbols which appears of it
appear in times so i times okay so
profile is a sufficient statistic for
probability multiset we can assume pazzo
sampling again also in the converse for
either two ideas so i'm rushing as you
can see so why do we want to use this
profiles and under Poisson sampling well
again because of this result you to
Valiant the result says that it's a very
nice result it bounds the variation
distance between two profiles under
poison sampling okay but suppose you
have passed on sampling you have two
distributions p and q and you have some
assumptions on them under pause on
sampling the variation distance between
the distribution on induce on the
profiles by p and q is bounded above by
this quantity the great thing here is
that you get this difference of moments
showing up here our difference of powers
i'm showing up here that's the great
thing yet okay so we have we have this
bound this we know by definition so what
how do we consider this P and Q here is
the construction P and Q are chosen to
be mixtures of be uniform distribution
so take D uniform distributions on
disjoint sets and mix them mix them by
these weights X I normalize by X&Y I
normalize this is a mixture construction
so they are mixture of D uniform
distributions that's what a P and Q are
it turns out for these specific
distributions you can exactly evaluate
this upper bounds and also evaluate a
different difference between our plinian
trophy so if you look carefully at this
upper bound what you what you will see
is here is the observation for these
particular choice of x and y for these
sorry these distributions if you have
this if you have x and y such that there
are h norm are equal for are between 1
and m minus 1 then you
distinguish between them with fewer than
k ^ 1 minus 1 over m samples so that's
from this valiant upper bound on the
other hand if you have X alpha different
from Y alpha the norm then there are any
entropies of order alpha are different
so this is what you want to construct
now we want to construct two vectors x
and y which are of d dimension such that
there are X moments match up to D minus
1 dimension and there diat vietnam are
different okay and in fact the alphas
norms are different for all alpha which
are non integer so can we give this
construction that's the question ok so
this is what we seek and I'll end with
this construction ok so that you can try
many things for this because it looks
like a sophisticated thing about some LR
norms but yeah they here gave a very
cute answer to me on whatsapp ok here is
the answer you start with this
polynomial and these are the roots of
polynomials X 1 X 2 X D now shift this
polynomial a little bit shift it a bit
up these are your y1 y2 y d what do you
know about the roots y1 y2 yd and X 1 X
2 X D well since these two polynomials
differ just by a constant the sum of
roots do not change sum of square of
roots will not change sum of cubes of
rule do not change only the sum of DF
power of the roots will change when
Newton girard inequality ie qualities
right so if you take a polynomial and
shift it just a little bit then the new
polynomials roots would have the same
sum of roots same sum of square of roots
same sum of cube of roots it's just that
the d8 sum of digit moment changes so
this is a construction ok this is a
construction for x and y start with any
polynomial let's say these roots are 1 2
3 D and then just shift it a bit new
roots are y1 y2 ID so these are I 1 by 2
by D and then we mix that mix uniform
distributions with these ways we said
our construction is slightly simpler
than what you hyung talked about in fact
just two this is the last idea so if
this was almost the last light so in
fact if you look at even lower bound it
was relating
the lower bound to polynomial
approximation but a rate approximation
there is no good answer for
multiplicatively small uniform
approximation and that's why we can't
use a technique here but the lower bound
which we showed was actually much
simpler than what he was talking about
it's a very simple proof fine so this is
the result estimate the Iranian topi of
order two it just requires order square
root K samples and it's a good proxy for
Shannon entropy in whatever application
you have and this graph looks very nice
and these things are discontinuous at
integer points and in general it's of
interest to look at sample complexity of
estimating other information magic
measures such as many divergences and
other Iranian rupees okay questions we
also the next speaker
so this one what what breaks down in
your estimation we don't know P right so
we are also estimating P itself and
rainy entropy is not uniformly
continuous for all P it's continuous in
alpha for each fixed P just thinking of
the specific estimator that you consider
where you you know take this and so I
didn't get your solution so are you
suggesting that you use some estimate
for alpha and use it for something close
to it I don't have a good answer to that
one one thing is in terms of the
previous two presentations if you look
at integer alphas the function becomes a
polynomial and so you can you know the
best polynomial approximation of a
polynomial is the column L itself for
alpha not integer the function is not a
polynomial so that gap somehow remains
so that's that's probably what's
happening but yeah it's slightly
mysterious